trees are about the most basic data
structure that you're ever going to come
across there they pervade computer
science and other subjects so let's talk
about them and the simplest definition
of a tree is that a tree is a connected
graph with no cycles in this setting
we're talking about simple graphs and
trees with undirected edges well in
order to make sense out of that we'd
better have a definition of a cycle
there's a picture of a typical tree but
to be precise
what's a cycle in a simple graph well
it's a closed walk of length greater
than 2 that doesn't cross itself so the
not crossing itself is the standard
definition of a cycle that we were using
in a directed graph it simply means that
it's a path except that the beginning
and end vertex are the same so it looks
like you start someplace at V and then
you go around to a and to W and it's all
distinct vertices as you go around in
this path except that the path ends
where it starts at V which is what keeps
it from being a path it makes it a cycle
now the length greater than 2 is what is
the difference between the definition of
cycle between simple graphs and directed
graphs in a directed graph it's
perfectly possible to have a self-loop
of length 1 that is an interesting and
important kind of cycle to have but we
forbid them in simple graphs because
there's no way to avoid having a cycle
of length 2 because you always have the
ability to go back and forth and cross
an edge that's not interesting and so we
don't consider that to be a cycle a
cycle then has to be of length greater
than 2 it also rules out the cycle of
length 0 which you get by taking a
vertex or by itself ok with that
technical definition we now know what a
cycle is in this simple graph and we
understand the definition of tree here
are some more pictures of trees simple
graphs with no cycles now they really
come up all the time and why is that
well there are family trees which you
may be familiar with where you're during
a picture of the descendants of a given
person and they keep branching out in a
you know tree structure as traditionally
displayed there are search tree
which come up the whole time in computer
science where you branch on the answer
to some question which tells you which
way to search next there are game trees
which we've already discussed in this
class which are used to define great
games and strategies their parse trees
that come up in in compiler technology
and in language theory and in the
responding trees which we're going to be
talking about some today now there in
addition to these places where trees
come up there are a lot of different
kinds of trees there's rooted trees
where there's some designated vertex
called the root and you think of getting
to all the other vertices from the road
there are ordered trees where when
you're at a given vertex there's a
distinct order in which you are going to
be in which the exit edges from a vertex
are there's a first one in the second
one the third one or a left one in the
next leftmost and so on so that there's
an order in which you can choose to
leave the vertex there are binary trees
in which each vertex has sort of two
ways out exactly or no ways out if it's
a so-called leaf and then there are
complete trees whose definition olive is
not important to us because we're not
going to consider any of these there's
also by the way directed trees in which
edges are have a direction as in a
digraph tree but we're not considering
any of these we're going to focus on
so-called pure trees which are unordered
unrooted undirected and that's what
we're talking about so let's examine
some more properties of trees and
equivalent definitions of trees it will
be important for theoretical reasons and
convenience to know lots of different
characterizations of trees so we've
starting off in the definition which
says it's a connected simple graph with
no cycles but there's other ways to
characterize it so an edge in a simple
graph is called a cut edge if when you
remove it from the graph two vertices
that used to be connected that is used
to have a path between them cease to
have a path between them so here's a
we'll graph illustration and that edge e
is a cut edge because if I delete it
then there are now two components there
used to be two vertices actually any of
the vertices here used to be connected
to any of the vertices there via that
edge but once I've deleted that edge all
of those vertices here and there that
used to be connected no longer are so
that makes via cut edge Oh F is not a
cut edge because even if I delete edge F
there is in fact still a path from every
vertex to every other vertex here so
that F is not disconnecting anything um
and as I say it's still connected after
you delete it so now we get a simple way
to characterize trees in terms of cut
edges because an edge is not a cut edge
if and only if it's on a cycle if you
think about that if it's on a cycle and
you cut an edge out of a cycle then
everything on the cycle still connected
by going the other way around the cycle
that doesn't use that edge and if it's
not on a cycle then in fact you can
think through that deleting it means
that there's not going to be two paths
between two things that it's at its
endpoints and so it will separate them
okay so another way then to define a
tree is to say a tree is a connected
graph where every edge is a cut edge
then as soon as you cut any edge out of
a tree it stops being connected that
yields another way to say that something
is a tree a tree is a simple graph that
is connected and is edged minimal which
again means that if you remove any edge
it stops having that property of being
connected so it's an edge minimal
connected graph that's kind of the
reason why trees are so important
because if you're trying to figure out a
way to get a whole bunch of things a
whole bunch of vertices connected a tree
is gonna have the minimum number of
edges that are sufficient to get them
all connected if you think about
different nodes in a network that need
to communicate with each other and you
want to know how many direct connections
do there have to be
between these communication centers in
order for everybody to talk to everybody
else
the answer is it's got to be a tree on n
vertices and a tree on n vertices is
going to have exactly n minus 1 edges so
that gives you I still another
equivalent definition of a tree a tree
is a connected graph that has n vertices
and n minus 1 edges a kind of dual way
to think about it is that a tree is an
acyclic graph that has as many edges as
it possibly could without having any
cycles so typically an acyclic graph
might not be connected but as long as
it's not connected you can keep adding
edges that will connect things up
without creating cycles but the minute
you get a tree so that everything is
connected you can't add another edge so
an edge 'men an edge maximal acyclic
graph is still another way to
characterize trees and maybe the most
useful way is to say that a graph in
which there is a unique path between any
two vertices is a tree so of course if
there's a unique path in particular
isn't passed so all the vertices have to
be connected but what makes it a tree is
that there aren't two different ways to
connect between two vertices because as
soon as the word that would be a cycle
and those are some of the basic ways
that trees can be formulated
equivalently and in fact there's lots
more but this is enough for today